[Music]
I am like super overwhelmed there's a
lot going on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians will address Kanye West's
hospitalization next season Plus Khloe
makes history with her new denim line
launch and Courtney shows off her super
hot bod
it was a world win a source tells ET a
few members of the Kardashian family
have filmed scenes talking about Kanye's
hospitalization however the rapper has
not filmed since he was admitted to UCLA
Medical Center last month for sleep
deprivation and exhaustion according to
another source Kim acts as an executive
producer on the reality show so
naturally she will have final say in
what makes it on air since what is the
right move meanwhile Khloe is the latest
Kardashian making big moves as a
businesswoman I feel good no matter what
size I am the 32 year old entrepreneur
launched her designer Jean brand good
American and made 1 million dollars on
the first day making the collection the
biggest didn't launch in apparel history
which is a blessing and big sis Kourtney
is back in the gym working on her hot
Mamba after being sick for three weeks
she documented her sweat session on
snapchat and proudly flaunted her sexy
physique in a gold glitter bodysuit on
Instagram
[Music]
you